so I have been I've been wrong about
something I not the first time won't be
the last but I have been wrong about
something I I have in the past been
dismissive about the issue of unjust
police shootings and I realized that I
was wrong to be dismissive I've come to
this realization over time but the last
few months have solidified it for me
especially I think there is there is a
problem here there is there's an issue
in the past I've basically taken the
position that there's not a real issue
it's all just hysteria and I still
maintain that there's a lot of hysteria
mixed into this clouding the the picture
but still when you sift through that
there is definitely an issue there's a
problem so I was wrong let's just start
by by looking at some recent episodes
most recently from just last week police
were responding to a shooting at a mall
in Alabama and in the process they
killed an apparent innocent man a Mantic
Fitzgerald Bradford who according to
witnesses was trying to direct shoppers
to safety he was trying to help and he
got killed in the process and to make
matters worse they apparently shot him
in the back three times according to an
autopsy report now this was an
independent autopsy the police have did
not admit this they have been not very
forthcoming about this case but
according to that opposite autopsy he
was shot in the back three times
an innocent man shot in the back three
times he did have a gun he himself had a
gun but he was carrying it legally with
a permit so it's a bit reminiscent of
the falando Castile shooting it was
another another man legally carrying a
gun not trying to harm anybody and yet
was shot and killed by police now if you
if you follow the trajectory here it
doesn't make the police look very good
in this case so originally they said
that the suspect in the shooting had
been killed and then a day later they
said okay actually the guy that we
killed probably was not the shooter and
then a few days after that they said
well he wasn't the shooter
he was brandishing a gun and then in
fact in a statement issued by the police
department they said we can say with
certainty mr. Bradford brandished a gun
but then later that same day they
clarified that the victim Bradford maybe
didn't actually brandish a gun maybe he
just had a gun in his hand which is not
the same thing as brandishing one but
again apparently he had the gun legally
and according to the family and
witnesses he was trying to help other
shoppers so there was also a similar
there was a similar case to this a month
before so in early November there was an
armed security guard Jamel Roberson was
killed by police after attempting to
detain a shop a shooter at a bar in
Chicago he was doing his job and police
killed him now there's a big problem
here because how are we as gun rights
advocates how are we supposed to make
the case that a good guy with a gun can
stop a crime if police are just going to
show up and shoot the first person with
a gun that they see when they arrive on
the scene so these are cases that as gun
rights advocates these are cases that we
should be really paying attention to
first of all because innocent human life
has been taken but also there's there's
an issue here with with gun rights if
police are killing legal gun owners
that's that's a huge issue and it does
seem rather conspicuous that gun rights
advocates for the most part say nothing
about these cases for the mutton out
with their art shot but for the most
part gun rights advocates say nothing
when police kill legal gun owners now
the month before before this so we've
got December in November now this was
back in thinking October may be late
September
a man named bottom gene was in his own
home in his apart
in Dallas when an off-duty cop came into
his home and shot him to death now she
has since been charged with murder she
claims that she accidentally went to the
wrong apartment
and she thought it was a he was an
intruder
and so she was barking commands at him
and he wasn't obeying the commands
because you know of a God forbid you
fail to obey the commands of an intruder
who just came into your home which she
was the intruder in this case but and
then she just she just killed him now
these are cases of from just the last
three months and there are plenty of
others
from recent times that have been equally
as egregious I mentioned falando Casteel
Tamir rice was a 12 year old child with
a fake gun shot and killed by police
last year there was Daniel shaver in
Arizona an unarmed man who was shot and
killed by police while crawling on the
ground literally begging for his life
and that's not an exaggeration it's on
video you can watch it he was on his on
the ground crawling begging for his life
and they shot and killed him
now you can look at these kinds of cases
as as I have done in the past and say
well these are these are isolated these
are isolated cases sure and you could
say most cops aren't killing innocent
people
sure the statistics show that this is a
non-issue really well hold on with that
because first of all I would submit that
three innocent men gunned down by cops
in three months is enough of an issue
already but actually the this is this is
an issue that's hard to quantify with
statistics there was a study done a few
years ago that found that the government
has been under counting the number of
civilian the number of civilians killed
by cops so the numbers and figures are
unreliable and we are left then to look
at individual cases we are left with the
anecdotal stuff and I think there's
enough of that to show that we have
the other thing is that the underlying
issue is not one that can really be
quantified by statistics and by studies
and so forth
the underlying issue has to do with the
way that police approach and deal with
interactions with the public the
question is whether or not police not
all but some a significant number may be
tend it to take an adversarial
aggressive assume everyone is a criminal
kind of approach when dealing with the
public that's the problem and you can't
just look at statistics and say yep or
say yeah or no or you know it did this
it's it's an issue that goes deeper than
statistics will show but here's the
problem
both sides of this issue have muddied
the waters both sides have made huge
mistakes and how they approach this
discussion so those who are critics of
police those who insist that there is a
problem with unjust killings they they
often make I think two big mistakes
first of all hyperbole they will speak
as though there's a nationwide Emmett
epidemic of rogue cops just prowling the
streets and gunning down innocent people
and that kind of exaggeration just is
not helpful the second mistake is they
always make it racial you know I'm not
saying that race plays no role in any of
this all of the all of the cases I
mentioned at the start involved black
men save for one Daniel shaver was white
but all the rest were black so I'm not
going to completely dismiss the racial
element of this I don't think we can do
that but I do think that racism is too
quickly assumed and I think that the
focus on race causes us to miss the
bigger picture there there probably are
racist cops out there just like there
are racist people of every of every in
every profession but but when we boil
this all down to a racial issue I think
it takes everything off track and we
miss we missed the point I think so
those are mistake
but then on the other side the defenders
of the police they also make some huge
mistakes and these are mistakes that I
myself have made for a long time with
respect to this problem number one they
rely too much on statistics they look at
some study or survey and they say look
this hardly ever happened so it's not a
problem
but as I said the figures are unreliable
because we're relying on the government
to provide them we're relying on the
government to tell on itself essentially
and and so that's a bit precarious also
even if these situations are
statistically rare they still happen and
they happen too much and so they have to
be dealt with if an innocent man is
laying dead in the street after being
gunned down by a trigger-happy cop it
doesn't do much good to assure his
family and the community that this is a
rare occurrence so what we still have a
dead innocent person here and we need to
figure out why and how this happened and
there needs to be justice the other
mistake that I think the defenders of
the police make is just in being much
too eager to excuse police kind of
reflexively and they'll excuse police
with I think really insufficient
rationales they'll say oh it's it's a
mistake you know people make mistakes
yeah but this mistake involves the
direct killing of an innocent person so
calling it a mistake doesn't cut it it
would be a mistake if I was driving
recklessly one night and I accidentally
plowed into a pedestrian and killed him
but I'm not going to escape justice by
calling it a mistake now the fact that
it's a mistake is going to is going to
weigh into the sentencing and everything
and and it's it would be worse if I did
it on purpose but mistakes that result
in the death of innocent people these
are more than just mere mistakes right
they'll also say well cops have
stressful jobs you know so they have
stressful jobs and so these things
happen yeah they do have stressful jobs
but what's your
this is a job that they signed up for
it's a job they are paid to do if they
aren't prepared for the stress they
should get another job if they can't
handle the stress without killing people
they should get another job nobody
forced you to be a cop nobody nobody
drafted you into law enforcement you
sign up you apply you volunteer and we
assistants who pay your salary and are
expected to respect and listen to you
should be able to expect in return that
you'll do your job without killing or
otherwise abusing innocent people that
shouldn't be too much to ask and we have
every right to demand it and then the
other excuses well cops are in
life-threatening situations they have to
protect themselves they they can't take
any chances that's the I've heard that
phrase you as many times they can't take
any chances
they can't um no I I think they can take
chances and they should their their
first instinct and responsibility should
be to protect innocent civilian life not
their own now I'm not saying they
shouldn't protect themselves but if
they're going to err on the side of
protecting themselves or protecting the
innocent they should go with the latter
because that's their job isn't it
if that's not their job then what are we
doing what's why do we have police if
their first job is just to protect
themselves even if it means killing
someone and erring on the side of well
look you know I mean it you gotta err on
the side of just killing an innocent
person if that's what makes you safer
then what what's the point
firemen have have dangerous jobs and
they have to protect themselves too as
they're as they're doing their jobs and
we can't expect them to you know put
themselves in situations that are you
know in danger situations without being
able to protect themselves but if a
fireman arrives at the scene of a fire
and there's a child trapped inside a
burning building and he could feasibly
rescue the child but he's too scared so
he lets the kid die instead we would
have every right to be outraged at him
and yeah he could say it's a dangerous
job I don't see you out here fighting
fires well true but you
end up for it that's not my job it's
your job that's the job that you signed
up to do if your first priority is
always going to be self-preservation why
did you take this job that's the
question if someone's free it's it's on
a selfish level it makes a lot of sense
that someone's first priority is gonna
be self-preservation that's what we many
of us operate that way but if that's how
you operate why are you in that job and
that's the problem we seem to accept
this idea that a cop's first priority
should always be to preserve his own
life even if it means possibly taking an
innocent life but that just seems really
backwards to me I thought protect and
serve meant protect and serve the
innocent the public not protect myself
so if you look at the Tamir rice case
for instance okay the child is it was a
kid who had a toy gun and and and you
could say well you know the cops didn't
know it was a toy the cops could have
been real and you know a bullet fired
from a from a real gun even if it's
fired by a twelve-year-old he is gonna
be just as lethal potentially as a
bullet fired you know by a by an adult
so so you know they didn't know and they
were being cautious okay but they knew
that it was a child they were dealing
with they had to know that it could have
been a toy gun they know that toy guns
exist right and they know that this is a
young boy and young boys play with toy
guns I mean they know all of that I
assume right so so then there's a
calculation the calculation is do I
pause for a few moments to assess the
situation in case this child really is
not a threat or do I shoot and kill him
just in case so that he doesn't hurt me
I think we should expect police officers
to value innocent life a little more
than that we should expect them to stick
their necks out a little bit more than
the cop who shot a child with a toy was
apparently willing to do
so where does this where does this where
does this come from what leads to these
situations where the innocent are being
gunned down by those who are sworn to
protect and serve them I think there are
I think there are several factors number
one as I've already said there seems to
have been a philosophical shift in the
way that we see law enforcement okay we
don't we don't see cops as servants of
the public anymore and I think many of
many cops don't see themselves that way
anymore instead they are simply
enforcers right law enforcement they're
enforcers and as enforcers their first
priority is enforcement over protection
of the innocent and certainly over
service to the innocent now this is not
how every cop approaches the job not at
all but there has been this general
philosophical shift I think second
factor there was a study done recently
showing that something like 20% of all
police officers are always or nearly
always angry and frustrated on the job
now they have plenty of reasons to be
cops deal much of the time with the
dregs of humanity cops deal with drug
addicts and domestic abusers and gang
members and so on and I imagine that can
make them jaded that can be frustrating
I'll never forget what a cop said to me
once while we were we were waiting at
traffic court so that he could testify
about a ticket that he'd given me a well
deserved ticket I was going like 25
miles over the limit and but as we were
waiting there he said to me he said you
know it's hard it's hard because the
only time I interact with normal decent
people in this job is when I'm pulling
them over to give them tickets the rest
of the time it's domestic violence and
drug related stuff and and that's always
stuck out to me and it shows the the
psychological toll that the job can take
on a police officer so they have reason
to be angry and bitter and frustrated I
would be if I did their job but on the
other side it's kind of scary to think
that 20% of the cops you come across
where
guns and badges and exercising an
enormous amount of authority over you
are angry and frustrated from the get-go
that's that's a that's that's a
frightening proposition considering how
much power and authority they have in
fact basically when you're when you're
confronted by a police officer in that
moment they basically have complete and
total power over you that's that's not
the way it's supposed to be that's not
the way it should be but that's the way
it is in in practice that's the way it
is because they've got the gun they've
got the badge and and that's all you so
if you if you don't listen to them they
could kill you that's that's the way it
goes so it is given that the way that
power dynamic works it's frightening to
think that so many of them are almost
always according to this survey
frustrated and angry now that leaves a
lot of cops who are not always
frustrated and angry or are rarely
frustrated an a but there's still a
large number who are and it's it's a
self-perpetuating thing right because
cops deal with a lot of just scumbags
frankly and so that can make some of
them bitter and resentful but then when
they're engaging with non scumbags with
just normal people you know a normal
person who happen to be speeding and
they got pulled over doesn't make it a
scumbag right you see just a normal
person but then they take that baggage
into their interactions with non
scumbags and then so then those non
scumbags are there their perception of
the police is going to be shaped by
these interactions and so now they're
gonna have a certain hostility towards
the police because of these negative
interactions I can say that you know the
number I don't know how many times I've
been pulled I've been driving for
whatever 17 years or something and maybe
I've been pulled over six times six or
seven times and most of that not even
speeding I think you know I had a brake
light out recently and of though
interactions a couple of them were
really nice and the the police officer
was really nice and friendly but then a
couple of them the police officer was
just a jerk to me for no reason
like it's just no reason going into the
interaction he was just a jerk there was
no reason for it I was I was being
completely respectful I was wasn't
arguing nothing like that I just was
doing as I was told and he was a jerk
now I don't hold that against them I
don't I don't let that paint my
impression of police officers in general
but I think the point is if you're a
just a regular civilian and you've had
several interactions with police and
they're being jerks to you for no reason
that could make you resentful so police
officers are resentful based on their
interactions the public is resentful
based on theirs and it's just it's just
a cycle and it leads to bad places third
third factor here and this circles back
to the first point with the
philosophical shift but I think we have
an exaggerated idea of the kinds of
power a cop is supposed to have and
conservatives who are usually big fans
of limited government and all of that
all of a sudden they lose that
conviction when it comes to the police
the skepticism the desire for
accountability the caution that
conservatives usually have when it comes
to the government when it comes to state
power suddenly that vanishes with
respect to police to the point where
some conservatives will even insist that
it is in our place to criticize but it
is these are agents of the state these
are public employees public servants we
have every right and every
responsibility to hold them accountable
and I think part of this very
authoritarian view that some people have
about the cops and some cops have about
themselves is the idea that if you
disobey an order from a police officer
or if you fail to follow it exactly as
instructed that alone is reason enough
to kill you I go back to the Daniel
shaver case
he was clearly no threat he was he was
clearly try trying to follow the orders
that were being barked at him but the
orders were confusing and they were
coming at rapid-fire speed and shaver
was obviously overwhelmed and terrified
when you've got people pointing guns at
you that can be frightening and it can
make you a little bit jumpy and it can
make you it can be difficult to follow
instructions in that situation so as he
was crawling on the ground crying
begging for his life he moved his his
hand slightly just to lift up his shorts
you could see in the video that his
shorts are falling down and so he
reached just to pick them us it's a
normal instinct that people have when
your pants are falling down you pick him
up and that's when they killed him now
when I talk about that when I talked
about that case at the time that it
happened some police defenders said well
it shouldn't have moved his arm he
that's what happens when you disobey the
police really so police are are what
Kings they're like these demigods who
can execute you on the spot if you dare
disobey them that really is peers to be
the the attitude that some people have
when it comes to the police and the
attitude that some police have and
that's that that's not what a police
officer is supposed to be that is not
how policing is supposed to work a man
should be able to pull up his pants and
protect his dignity without being shot
in the chest okay I really feel like
that shouldn't be a controversial
statement and you could say well he's
moving his arm maybe maybe he's pulled
reaching for a gun well I think it
should've been really you know you you
look at the video it should be really
obvious to anyone that he didn't have a
gun um but even if he did okay
and it's also should be really obvious
to anyone that he is trying to follow
the orders he's crying and crawling and
doing what they tell him so that all
should be obvious to anyone and it
should be obvious to police they're the
ones who are paid to be in these
situations they should be able to make
those assessments but what I'm saying
even if he was reaching for a gun let's
say even even if
was in the put you know there were three
guys with guns pointed directly at him
he was crawling on the ground even if he
did grab a gun there they would have
enough time by the time they actually
see him they actually see him grab the
gun there is enough time for them to
then open fire I know you could say well
it's a split-second thing it's not
literally a split-second though like it
takes unless you are unless you're John
Wayne or something it takes you more
than a second to go from here to grab
the gun to pull it now I know it's not a
couple minutes it's a short amount it's
a few seconds but what I'm saying is
that police officers should value life
enough that they're willing just to wait
for a second and without assuming
without jumping to this conclusion and
then killing someone just in case
because that's what this is they let's
be clear about what they they killed him
just in case like he probably didn't
have a gun but maybe he was and just in
case let's kill him to be safe
that's IIIi I submit again that is not
how the police should operate let's kill
them just in case
that is a shoot first ask questions
later kind of thing let's shoot him
first and then go see oh he didn't have
a gun well oops
no it's not an oops that's an innocent
man that you just killed he's dead no
he's got a family he's dead he's got a
life that's gone this is not an oops
this is not a my bad yeah if they had
waited one more second they would have
put themselves in a little bit more of
harm's way but I think that that's their
responsibility and it's not even that
much of harm's way because there are
three of them standing over him with
guns already drawn so it's just it to
wait one more second before before
pulling that trigger yeah it increases
the threat to them by by some but not by
that much but the trade-off is in
increasing the threat to themselves by
just a little bit they they get to
preserve the life of an innocent person
and I and I think that's a trade-off
that they should make and if again if
you're not willing to make that trade
then I what are you doing in that job
he doesn't do any good to say well it's
easy for you to say Matt yeah it is easy
for me to say I didn't sign up for that
job you did you know it's it's really
easy if if a if a let's take a surgeon
in a trauma ward surgeons and trauma
wards have very stressful jobs very
stress probably the most stressful job
one of the most stressful jobs you could
have on earth is that job well and they
make mistakes and these are
life-and-death situations but if a if a
surgeon engages in blatant medical
malpractice and kills a person in the
process we are going to criticize them
and we're going to be outraged and we're
going to expect accountability and it
doesn't do any good for the surgeon to
say well I don't see you doing this job
is a difficult job you try being a
surgeon yeah you're right I'm not doing
it I didn't say I'm not getting paid for
it I didn't sign up for you did you took
on that responsibility and so it's on
you it's not on the rest of us it's on
the person who does the job if I hire a
plumber to come to my house and he
screws up the job really badly and then
he can't say why I didn't see you fixing
it I I hired you to do it this is the
Jui this is your job so yes yes you're a
better plumber than me but you're not
good enough right so I think this is the
you know this is just it is an issue and
and on both sides I think we need to we
need to reassess the way that we look at
this and I also think the last thing
I'll say is a you know I think that we
should and this is something I'm working
on as well but we should make an attempt
when you've got a whole bunch of people
a whole group of people saying something
taking a position on something and
insisting that there's a problem with
something I think that
the intelligent and the right and the
intelligent thing to do is to just stop
and at least listen to what they're
saying so there are a whole lot of
people in this country especially people
in the black community but not just them
who are saying look there's a problem
with the way that police operate in the
way that we approach policing and
there's an issue here and so I think no
matter where you stand on it we have to
at least stop and listen to what they're
saying and the points that they're
raising especially when they're talking
about their own experiences and they're
saying look here are my experiences with
cops we have to stop in at least listen
and I think once you do that you
discover that yeah there there is a
problem it might not be racism it might
not be a problem as widespread as the
way that it's painted by some people but
there is at least an issue that's worth
looking at all right we'll we'll leave
it there thanks for watching thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed